the Duggar family in turmoil et has the  details a source from inside the Duggar  family tells ET Jill and Jess's TLC  special has turned into a circus members  of the family are disagreeing with  elements of the special including  pudding and a Duggar on camera at a time  like this  Ana's husband Josh Duggar has been  through multiple major scandals this  year in July he admitted to molesting  five underage girls when he was young  teen including his sisters Jill and  Jessa then in August it was discovered  Josh was cheating on his wife using  Ashley madison.com our source feels  certain members of the family are quote  more focused on readings and a paycheck  than actually focusing on the issues at  hand we're told some family members have  chosen not to participate in the special  because of what the family has been  through the special will focus on Jill  and Jessa's lives as wives and mothers